good morning ankh life it's from an
organization called working it's partly
owned by the UK government we're working
in the region trying to help unemployed
people into private sector jobs through
government funding the key thing that
needs to change is understanding and
managing expectations jobseekers need to
understand that I have to change the way
they view work and employers
particularly those from the Western
world need to appreciate the value that
that a local person an Arab would be
they Emirati sodium Arnie can actually
bring to their organizations and through
that shared understanding we can
actually actually see a relaxation in
the reliance on expatriates and a more
informed aggressive careers for Arabs
thank you